good afternoon everybody thank you so
much for coming today and thanks for the
organizers of the conference for
inviting me as somebody who participates
in a lot of conferences over the years I
sometimes recoil whenever I get an
invitation to come to a conference
because so often they end up doing
little more than just kind of spreading
dreariness in part because the intent is
to gather together and talk about instit
tions and the way they're so
fundamentally corrupted and the ways in
which it creates all kinds of Social
pathologies and it's sort of true that
these institutions are corrupted and
occasionally at these conferences people
remember oh maybe it's not such a great
idea to spend 15 minutes just talking
about the reasons why everyone should be
so pessimistic and they kind of add on
this cursory nod to the fact that oh if
we come together maybe we can fix things
but it's a very sort of cursory and
trivial attempt to spread optimism in
what excited me about this conference
what excites me about it the reason I
came at pretty far distance to
participate in it is because it's
animated in the first instance by the
notion that we can reimagine something
that is better that's exciting it's not
just an afterthought but the primary
focus this idea that we can create
societies from scratch we can reimagine
a way that so many of the pathologies
that we're all aware of can be
eliminated or cured by starting from a
different foundational Point all that
said I do think it's necessary to spread
a little bit of dreariness because in
order to imagine a kind of better new
alternative I think it's important to
talk about the reasons why that's even
necessary in the first place what went
wrong with our current institutions in
part because that's the key context for
the idea of creating something different
but also because there's so much to
learn in looking at and deconstructing
and analyzing the current the status quo
in order to learn what went wrong so as
to not replicate it in whatever new is
being created and so this group of the
conference is intended to think about
media and the way in which it can be
Freer and more constructive and
healthier and the way in which I think
Civic Liberties just core Civic rights
can be better preserved not allow their
erosion things like free speech Free
Press due process the kind of
foundational points for a just Society
and for me when I think about those
Concepts and in particular how things
can go off track so easily my frame of
reference is the 911 attack not the
attack itself but the response to it in
in the west generally in the United
States in particular and one of the
lessons that I think is so crucial to
always keep in mind is how easily and
how quickly things can go arai as a
result of either a genuine attempt to
respond to a crisis or a cynical attempt
to exploit one to wield even greater
power in the part of institutions of
authority and I think one example is
particularly Vivid in understanding that
concept and that was the enactment of
the Patriot Act in the days and weeks
after the 911 attack at the time after
911 happened in the United States there
was a sense that we need to unite we
need to give the government anything
asked for in the name of keeping the
population safe of avoiding a repetition
of an event like that that really was
the climate things were 80 and 90% in
favor of whatever measures the
government wanted but even in that
climate where there was a lot of
acquiescing a lot of acceptance of new
proposed laws the Patriot Act even then
was considered very radical almost
unthinkably so this kind of a radical
departure from the promise of the
American founding of the way in which we
thought about the United States and how
powers of detention and surveillance
were supposed to
function and people said that even when
they weren't saying that about many
other things this seems dangerous this
seems authoritarian this seems over the
line and in fact that sentiment was so
widespread that they needed a way to
assuage those concerns and the way they
found was to say we're going to enact
the Patriot Act but when we do we're
going to put in a provision that say
it's it's just temporary it's only
designed to address the immediate y of
this particular crisis but don't worry
it's going to go away after 4 years
unless in the extremely unlikely case
Congress says this emergency is still
present and still just as acute and then
they'll renew it unless that happens and
is extremely unlikely four years from
now that emergency will still be so
acute it will go
away here we are 22 years later and not
only is the Patriot Act still completely
in place in exactly the form that it was
when it was acted almost no
reforms when it comes up every four
years for Renewal it's barely even
debated anymore nobody even notices it
there's nothing cons there's nothing
radical anymore that people think about
the Patriot Act because it's been so
normalized it's just part of the
political Woodwork and it became that
way really very quickly even in 2005
when it was time to renew it the sense
that this was something radical had
dissipated because it was no longer
radical it was now foundational to how
our society functions and that I think
is a crucial lesson that these things
happen very quickly and imp perceptively
but very
potently and the next I time that I
really kind of focused on the way in
which these dangers can happen is as you
see here the work that I did in 2013
along with the documentarian Laura poess
and several other of my colleagues in
journalism when I worked with Edward
Snowden the NSA whistleblower to reveal
something people had suspected but never
had confirmation of and had no idea was
so extreme which was the revelations of
mass indiscriminant
spying that had taken place in the
United States justified by the threat of
911 and this was the story the very
first story on June 6th that we
published it's about exactly 10 years
ago just a few months uh Beyond 10 years
and you can see the story was that the
NSA and at the time it was just Verizon
we came very quickly to realize it was
not just Verizon but every company was
collecting Millions and tens of millions
and even hundreds of millions of records
of every telephone call that Americans
were having soon after we realized it
was extended the internet and the reason
it made such an impact was because of
the magnitude of it the fact that there
was basically nothing that the NSA
either wasn't seeking to C to collect
and analyze or in fact had collected and
analyze there was a slide here when
every anyone asked me what was the most
significant story I always say there's
no one significant story The most
significant part was how
unlimited was their vision of what a
surveillance State should be that it was
literally the elimination of privacy in
the digital age here you see just one of
the slides that came from the NSA
describing what their surveillance
posture was and there you see sniff it
all know it all collected it all process
it all exploit it all partner it all it
was not collect all terrorist
Communications collect all threatening
Communications it was collected all and
so many of the documents demonstrated
that wasn't just aspiration but
something that had in fact taken place
but the thing that was different about
the Patriot Act was that in this case
there was an attempt there was a
reaction to it a a sense that well there
are things we should be able to do to
guard against it to try and limit its
reach and Edward Snowden himself after
he enabled us to do this reporting
didn't just disappear in fact he began
working on what those Solutions were and
a lot of people had already been working
on them as well here you see an
interview in 2015 he's with the
intercepts security Chief Michael Lee
informational security Chief and he had
an interview about how to reclaim your
privacy and it focused a lot on
encryption and private sector means and
individual means to guard against this
sort of incursion and encryption became
the focal point of privacy activist and
it was like an arms race where the NSA
was trying to invade encryption and
people were trying to build it and here
you see one of the stories actually that
the NSA had targeted encryption very
complicated sophisticated encryption
that a lot of Security Experts assumed
had been impenetrable or at least very
very difficult to breach and in fact the
SSA was spending a quarter of a billion
dollars a year and had in fact breached
them you see there the sub headline
Security Experts say programs undermine
the fabric of the internet it was the
foundational means of safegard regarding
privacy the NSA had breached it and
people were shocked by that but over the
last 10 years this has been the kind of
back and forth the attempt to find a way
to ensure we still have privacy in the
digital age while the governments that
want to surveil not just the west but
all over are working constantly to
overcome it and so for me this framework
of how to ensure that the internet
cannot be a place where people can
freely organize and speak without being
monitored has an analog in similar
attempt to ensure that the internet is a
place where free expression can no
longer exist where there are ways that
governments have to essentially control
the flow of information on the internet
the internet itself was supposed to be
this Innovation that ensured a new way
of communicating that citizens around
the world could organize and speak with
one another without having to be
dependent upon a centralized state or
corporate Authority and yet exactly the
opposite is true I think one of the most
most potent examples that really
indicated to people the extremity of the
problem was in the wake of the Banning
by all big tech companies of Donald
Trump when he was still the sitting
president of the United States an
alternative site was created where that
said we're not going to allow censorship
we're not going to accept orders from
institutions of authority about what to
censor we're going to allow free speech
to flow and it was a application called
parlor and in the wake of Donald Trump's
Banning from Twitter and Facebook it
became the number one most downloaded
app in all of the United States more
than Facebook and Tik Tok and uh Twitter
itself it was the most popular people
were going in droves to it because of
the promise of free speech and the
ability to be free of
censorship and yet once people in
Washington saw that it was that popular
they began publicly calling on Apple and
Google to exclude it from its uh
download store so you couldn't download
parlor any further you couldn't get
updates and then they also demanded that
Amazon booted off of its uh hosting
services and with 48 Hours parlor was
crippled and really never recovered and
that showed what happens when there's a
dependency on companies that are so
centralized that they're vulnerable to
these kinds of censorship demands and
there's also a kind of uh related
attempt to create this industry called
the dis information industry that is
intended to ensure that censorship looks
not like political censorship or an
intent to quash descent but as a sort of
databased or politically neutral way of
arbitrating Truth and falsity so that we
promise people you're going to have an
internet free of falsity who wouldn't
want that but of course the question
becomes who are the people issuing these
determinations and when you look just a
little bit below the hood you always
find the same things here is one group
that the media loves to site for what is
and is not disinformation it's called
The Institute for strategic dialogue
they always have these very benign
sounding names who could be opposed to
that it's just an Institute for
strategic dialogue everybody loves
strategic dialogue and if you look
though at who funds it you always find
the same set of billionaires that have a
certain ideology behind it and then you
also have uh sites that are related to
the US Security State or British
intelligence or Western European
intelligence that also
funds this Arbiter of what is truth and
falsity and if you look at media Outlets
like the Washington Post whenever they
say oh we have to censor something it's
Russian disinformation they'll always
site this group The Institute for
strategic dialogue or one that's very
similar to it that is funded by Western
governments even though you wouldn't
know that they sound like a very neutral
sounding name so this has created
genuine problems with free expression on
the internet and what a lot of people
are now doing is seeking to find ways to
rectify that I last year agreed to move
to rumble which is a site devoted to
free expression they uh have they're not
available in France if you're in France
and you want to watch my program or
other programs on Rumble they're not
available in France because France
ordered Rumble to remove certain
platforms certain programs from its
platform and they said we're not going
to take orders from the the French
government about who we can and can't
allow on our site we're a free speech
platform we allow everybody and the
French said if you don't we're going to
cut you off the IP level so rumble's not
available in France they are very
devoted to this idea they'd rather lose
markets than accept censorship the
problem is that even though Rumble has
done so much to avoid the problem that
parlor had they they built their own
servers they are completely insulated at
the end of the day they're still
dependent upon things like governments
governments can cut them off at the IP
level or there can be pressure put on ad
advertisers and there are a lot of
people who believe that no matter how
devoted to free a free internet and Free
Speech a company like Rumble is it's
never going to work until it everything
is decentralized until there are
protocols like Odyssey Jack dorsy is a
big believer in this he says his biggest
regret about Twitter is that there was a
centralized place you could go to
Twitter and government go there and
pressure those people there to to censor
and they have the power to do it and
they're always going to be vulnerable to
those kinds of Demands that the only way
to have a free internet or a free media
is once you have full
decentralization and so I think when
we're talking about creating new
communities new leaders new parallel
cities we have to understand that these
Dynamics are very intoxicating they're
part of human nature to want to control
the free flow of ideas and even the most
benevolent people often succumb to them
for malevolent reasons out of
self-interest and I think there are a
lot of lessons to learn from how these
erosions have taken place but also the
reactions to try and guard against them
thank you very
much